now the head of the un aid agency for
palestinians says there will be
no peace in the region if the root
causes of the conflict between israel
and palestine aren't resolved
philippe lazarini was speaking in gaza
two days after a ceasefire was agreed to
end an 11-day conflict there
more than 250 people have been killed
most of them palestinians in the
occupied territory
i am deeply frustrated at this senseless
episode
of extreme violence that killed civilian
destroyed infrastructure and threw
gaza back several years but restoring
a sense of normality is not enough
it is not a replacement for peace or for
the human rights
of all the root causes of the conflict
remain the occupation the forced
displacement of which we had a strong
reminder
in cherry lately the blockade and the
cycle
of violence all remain this
must be resolved meanwhile both
of the border crossings between israel
and gaza have now been closed
the checkpoint was briefly opened on
friday allowing foreign journalists to
enter the strip
but israel has also now closed access to
gaza from the sea
well let's speak to al jazeera suffolk
he joins us now
from gaza stafford i see the un is
calling for unimpeded access and now
we're actually seeing this instead
what reasons are being given for these
closures
well this is gaza normally with the
israelis they don't go give
specific reasons except for security
reasons nobody understand what are the
security reasons because
normally the israelis they don't give
explanation
uh that's why most of the time gaza has
been
the crossings of gaza has been closed
for several years and this opened also
the
the discussion of the issue of gaza gaza
is considered
the biggest open air prison in the world
it's controlled by three crossings
two controlled by egypt by israel one
for personal one for good
and the third one controlled by egypt
most of the of the time is closed for
security reasons because of the uh
the safety or the unstability in the
sinai so
gaza has been uh under emergency bases
most of the let's say the food
or the aid or even for the industry
comes through gaza under specific very
restricted measures
controlled by the israelis so after
before the war
or before the latest escalation days
before they closed the sea
they closed the two uh only crossing
controlled by the israelis
one for personnel called areas and one
for uh or for individual court
errors and one for the commercial
exchange which is gone
by the way most of the products in god
produced in gaza are not allowed to go
to be exported to the to the outside
world
the gaza used to export lots of products
including furniture
clothes vegetables etc but not anymore
which afflicted and damaged
the economy uh egypt today
there are 130 truckloads of uh
humanitarian aid vegetables uh
medicine clothes etc managed to
to cross into gaza today now yuan is
depending on
in rafah crossing to bring uh the
essential elements
that we we learned that from tomorrow at
4g
uh seven local until uh to uh
to the am israel will i will open the
crossing
exceptionally uh to allow the foreign
media also
the journalists to leave the gaza strip
but still there is no indication for
longer term or serious opening for the
crossing the sea of gaza is still closed
three thousand fishermen are not allowed
to to go to the sea and
and re resume uh the fishing also still
the roads of gaza are still closed the
municipalities trying to fix as much as
they could
to uh to solve the problem of the
traffic jam
they're on the ground for us in gaza
thank you so much suffolk
well meanwhile the u.s secretary of
state says president joe biden is
committed to a two-state solution
anthony blinken who's expected to visit
israel later this week himself
says the immediate concern is rebuilding
gaza
it's vitally important that uh that
palestinians
uh feel hope uh and have opportunity
and can live in security just as it is
for israelis and there should be equal
measures
and in a in a democratic society uh that
is i think an obligation
of the uh of any government so
ultimately i think that that
uh that hope that security that dignity
can will be found in a palestinian state
but
meanwhile uh we have to do everything we
can both to address the immediate
situation which is
humanitarian reconstruction in gaza
starting to improve people's lives in a
concrete way
our diplomatic editor james baze has
more now from west jerusalem
if the u.s is not engaged diplomatically
then there is no diplomacy on this issue
so what secretary blinken says when he
arrives in the region will be very
closely watched
as are his words as he prepares to
travel here he'll be here on wednesday
and thursday
but in the last couple of hours he's
been on u.s tv on the abc
network where he was asked about the
conflict
he was asked about u.s arms sales
to israel because most of those
weapons that were bombarding gaza were
made
in the u.s and were u.s funded he said
that
israel has a right to defend itself he
was asked about iran
backing hamas and potentially providing
it with weapons he said that iran is
engaged
in many fronts in the middle east but he
then made the point
that's why pursuing a nuclear deal with
iran
is so important he didn't want to get
into blaming iran it was clear
because of course there are those
negotiations about the nuclear deal
ongoing
in vienna they've made considerable
progress but they're now at a very
delicate stage he also made it clear
that something has to change
particularly
with palestinians that they should feel
some dignity
and some hope otherwise this was all
going to happen once again